abdella Ali Mamoun est avec nous merci
merci d'être là on a on a on va prendre
les dernières questions alors Monsieur
liim moi je suis très contente de vous
écouter ce ce soir parce
qu'effectivement ce matin quand je vous
ai entendu chezapuline de malerbre
j'étais un peu effrayé et et et je voilà
et là je suis extrêmement rassurée je
trouve que ce que vous dites est clair
net précis euh sans ambiguïé et je pense
que c'est important de vous entendre
parler parce que moi souvent ici je
parle avec mon ami mundir et Gill qui
sont tous les deux de confession
musulmanes et on on on se dispute
souvent justement par rapport à la
parole des imames aujourd'hui en France
et moi je parle souvent de l'imam
shalgoumi et là à chaque fois on dit non
mais lui ça compte pas lui c'est un
mauvais imam limite lui il est Islam non
non eux de ah non j'ai pas dit que c'est
un mauvais bah non vous dites que non
non non non non j'ai dit qu'il avait du
mal à conjuguer le verbe être et avoir
c'est pas c'est vous AZ dit qu'
représentit pas les musulm tout cas qui
n représent et moi je voulais savoir
alors pourquoi donc justement pourquoi
il y a pourquoi il y a il y a une telle
comment dire haine envers cet imam
chalgoui pourquoi c'est donc c'est un
mauvais imam pourquoi à chaque fois il
pourquoi il vit sous protection
policière alors que normalement c'est
une religion de paix pourquoi c'est à ce
point-là compliqué quand on quand on est
par dans la marche contre
l'antisémitisme quand on est un musulman
et qu'on et qu'on est caché parce qu'on
a honte de dire qu'on est dans cette
mche contre l'antisémitisme quel que
soient les propos que pourrait tenir
chalgoumi qui soit français ou on va
dire l'humour ou je sais quoi mais non
c'est pas de l'humour c'est la réalité
c'est un un homme qui ne sait pas parler
français et qui malheureusement a été
mis en avant et qui provoque une
certaine frustration dans la composante
musulman à qui on oblige excusez-moi à
qui on oblige euh d'être représenté par
un un par une personne qui même un
enfant de 3 ans parlerit parle mieux
français que lui c'est la réalité ça
c'est un premier point sur la forme
maintenant sur le fond maintenant sur le
fond un imam c'est un homme de paix moi
je suis un homme de paix j'appelle à la
paix je suis pas dans le camp d'Israël
ni dans le camp palestinien je suis pour
la paix je dois être un acteur un agent
qui doit promouvoir la réconciliation
hier encore hier monsieur chalgoui
disait que Israël doit gagner la guerre
et nous que je suis du côté d'Israël et
j'espère qu'elle va euh gagner la guerre
je dis ah donc ça veut dire qu'il est
dans le camp de la guerre je suis désolé
un imam ne doit pas parler comme ça ni
même un rabin ni même un curé les les
hommes de foi doivent être des hommes
qui doit qui doit être des hommes pour
promouvoir la paix et le C la guerre
contre le Hamas oui oui il parlait
contre bah la guerre il parle de la Guer
on peut le comprendre non la guerre
contre le Hamas on est tous à vouloir la
guerre contre le Hamas on veut tous
l'extermination du Hamas oui bien sûr
mais est-ce qu'on le veut au détriment
des populations palestiniennes ah ça je
sais pas ça vous bah oui mais le
problème c'est ça il y a 11 il y a 11000
morts il y a des milliers de morts en
tout cas en tout cas des milliers de
morts ça c'est sûr on pourrait pas on
pourrait pas me faire dire autre chose
hein moi je vois des vidéos qui sont
atroces sur Internet sont aussi aussi
atroces de ce qui s'est passé le voir
même euh en nombre puisque on parle de
nombre attendez le nombre est beaucoup
plus importantcun journaliste
indépendant à Gaza hein vous devez le
savoir je dis il y a aucun journaliste
indépendant à mais pourquoi on n pas
est-ce que vous croyez que les les
gazaou ch mais c'est ça qui est horri
est-ce que vous croyez les
gazqu petre000 mors à gaz c'est
peut-être une fausse information on va
se faire défoncer on pas le droit de
laisser parler fake new je suis désolé
rien ne dit qu'il a 11000 morts rien ne
dit d'ailleurs de la même
façonyz j' sais rien vouz voir vidéos
sont on vous montre les vidéos prou a
des milliers Mor est-ce que vous voyez
pas est-ce que vous voyez pas est-ce que
vous voyez pas la banque de Gaza qui a
été
complètementite est-ce qu'on voit pas
aujourd'hui la bande de Gaza qui est
totalement détruite pratiquement est-ce
que oui ou non on le voit ça on le voit
forcément il y avait des habitants tout
à fait bon ben alors forcément ils sont
morts parce que si si on voit comre comm
sond com effondr qu'ils sont mort il VI
je ne connais pas le chiffre
de je refuse de donner une fake news et
d'approuver une
fake je n'is
rienoutez écoutez moi la solution c'est
que Israël donne la permission à des ONG
de rentrer à Gaza et de compter les
morts bien israël
refuse encore un problème qui vient
d'Israël et des PAL voulais dire non moi
je dis que il fait du bien cet homme-là
cet homme-là il fait du bien ce soir
parce que moi je voulais pastin non mais
pas ce matin ce matin ce qu'il a dit ce
matin là moi je suis comme vous je
reconnais pas quelqu'un qui a parlé
comme ça moi je l'ai pas vu j'étais au
boulot je reconnais pas quelqu'un qui
qui qui a dit ça ce matin ce qu'il a dit
ce soir chaque chroniqueur l' a été de
sa question tout un par un vous avez
rentrer chez vous vous faites le replay
toutous un par un vous lui avez posé une
question est-ce que vous condamnez il
vous répond oui à chaque fois la marche
il vous a répondu pourquoi il a pas été
tout tout tout tout tout il a tout mis
dedans il a tout coché dedans il a fait
plaisir à tout le monde et vous
continuez encore à lui dire non il y a
pas 11000 morts alors s'il y en a pas
11000 peut-être qu'il y en a 4000
peut-être qu'il y en a 3000 même s'il y
en a 200 innocents c'est trop on peut
aussi dire on peut écouter deux versions
les gars comment on va aller vers la
paix si on dit tout le temps non il
s'est passé que le 7 octobre le 7
octobre on le on le condamne c'est
dégueulasse ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre c'est des innocents c'est des
tirs au hasard pour moi c'est terroriste
je le condamne mais on peut pas dire que
ce qu'il dit là lui il l'a inventé de de
l'arrê de bus je je l'ai repris sur le
chiffre de 11000 mort parce qu'on sait
rien la V de gaz détru les G les G
attendsends pas
n gaz B de gaz les gens sont levés
attention il y a une bombe on se barre
non si la ville elle est détruite JAC tu
peux pas dire fake news fake
news en 24 he vous voulez milli
personn mais c'est ce qu'ils ont demandé
ils ont demandé que 24 24 he
a demandé au Hamas de déplacer la
population vers le sud vers le camp de
reconna
pas estce que l'État d'Israël a
demandé au dirigants du Hamas de
déplacer la population vers le sud de la
bande
gaz ils vont tous se déplacer dans avec
civil déplacé comm pars
on et les caches d'armes et les caches
d'armes qui sont placés sous les
hôpitaux est-ce que ça c'est de nature
par laisse par ici sur ce plateau moi
j'ai été le premier à condamner le Hamas
de mouvement terroriste j'ai été le
premier bien évidemment j'en ai eu les
retours d'accord des deux parties je me
souviens sur ce plateau oui bien
évidemment mais là je parle de moi donc
le mais on a on était sur ce plateau les
gens disaient et je me souviens il
condan la masse il disit 8 mai et on
était ferme il y avait pas de 8 mai on
condamne point là ce qui se passe est ce
que vous êtes en train de faire avec
l'imam comme l' l'a souligné mon
confrère il a il a répondu à tout il
peut pas faire mieux et vous dites oui
mais non il y a pas de 8
catastrot il y a un mot il y a un mot en
France madame de Maler qui qui me fait
dire moi je dis pas elle me fait dire
oui bien sûr c'est elle qui me fait dire
des
chosesors parle à ma place rédemption
monsieur monsieur l'imam a eu rédemption
il est en train de vous
dire comment pardon tu vois c'est encore
les 8 mai de toi machin donc si c'est
pas le Rapp c'est toujours cette espè
cette espèce de chose qui va gêner tu
sais il peut pas être plus clair écoutez
je vais vous dire une chose écoutez même
ce soir excusez-moi même ce soir comme
ce matin comme cet après-midi surbfm TV
je n'ai jamais sollicité l'autorisation
de monsieur le recteur de la Mosquée de
Paris et je ne parle en aucun cas en son
nom je ne suis ni le porte-parole de la
Grande Mosquée de Paris ni même
porte-parole du recteur monsieur le
recteur est suffisamment majeur et
vacciné intelligent pour défendre
lui-même le la mosquée qu'il représente
moi aussi aujourd'hui j'ai effectivement
une une collaboration et un travail que
j'accomplis parce que je pense qu'il
faut une unité des musulmans pour
essayer de faire avancer les choses en
France pour promouvoir un islam qui
s'intègre parfaitement dans le paysage
français et dans lequel on soit en
harmonie avec les lois et les valeurs de
la République c'est ce que nous
travaillons au sein de la de la Mosquée
de Paris et depuis des des mois et des
mois on travaille dans ce sens-là on
travaille même avec des juifs et des
rabins monsieur Moché Lévin en fait
partie monsieur cors tous les jours
chaque fois chaque occasion invité à la
mosquée de Paris et vice-versa donc les
relations sont conviviales et
fraternelles et cordiales depuis très
longtemps avec la composante je n'ai pas
de leçons à recevoir
sur le fait que
aujourd'hui je je suis de tout cœur avec
la population et la composante juive de
France qui a été VI victime
d'antisémitisme depuis le 7 octobre d'un
nombre choquant que que ce matin j'ai
été moi-même estomaqué je dis c'est pour
cela alors que pour nous on était
persuadé que non la communauté musulmane
depuis le début de de de la guerre a eu
une attitude digne et cetera nous
pensions qu'il nexistait pas d'acte
antisémite musulman et là c'est pour
cela qu'on me dit si si il y a eu 1240
donc permettez-moi d'avoir quand même la
le le le droit de de m'interroger sur à
la fois qui qui est à l'origine de C
l'origine de ces actes est-ce que ce
sont des actes néonazis est-ce que ce
sont des actes musulmans j'ai demandé
des détails jamais j'ai prononcé preuve
ou doute j'ai dit j'ai demandé des
détails pour justement travailler
justement le constat et
voilà les gensont pas entendu l'avez
entenduci monsieur d'avoir été avec nous
le soir allez vous coucher là
maintenant matin je suis debout vous
avez fait combien d'émissions
aujourd'hui 12 he vous avez fait combien
d'émissions euh trois TR tris en plus
trois plus bon des des choses
personnelles que j'ai dû faire en dans
la journée c'est important de faire des
ch ou effectivement et donc depuis ce
matin je me suis pas reposé mais il
fallait il fallait que je vienne sur
votre plateau et et merci en tout cas
m'avoir invité c'est la première fois je
suis content d'être là avec toi
aujourd'hui avec plaisir et c'est ça a
été votre préférée quand même cette
émission ouais oui est elle est beaucoup
plus conviviale en plus il y a un public
il y a un public formidable
merci d'avoir été là alors on pass c'est
moi qui vous applaudit messieur
dames merci merci d'